Welcome back everyone this is my marvel video
for the new Spider-Man, Doctor Strange lawsuit
that you may have read about this morning.
Yes, it is a big deal and it's no coincidence
that this is happening right before Spider-Man
no way home comes out in theaters will explain
what's going on is not quite as dire is it
sounds like even though it is a big deal.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos there will
be a lot of big Spider-Man stuff happening
venom let there be carnage is coming out next week too
So I'll be doing post credit scene videos
Easter eggs for everything, but recently you
probably saw the news that Marvel was in the
middle of a brand-new lawsuit over Spider-Man
and Doctor Strange with the estate of Steve
Ditko so that's right.
Even though there is a big lawsuit over the
black widow movie with Scarlet Johansson happening.
That's completely separate the state of Steve
Ditko is now getting into it with Marvel over
the Spider-Man and Doctor Strange characters.
Even though he passed away in 2018, his heirs
still control his estate and they're the ones
that are fighting with Marvel what happened
recently, though, is that they tried to send
the copyright license termination notice to
marvel for the Spider-Man and Doctor Strange
characters for the rights to those characters.
So technically is them trying to terminate
marvel's in Sony's ability to do anything
with Spider-Man and Doctor Strange that includes
all the comics, the movies, the toys the videogames
anything that was created in the amazing Spider-Man
comics amazing fantasy journey into mystery
and Strange tales those of the original comics
where the Spider-Man, Doctor Strange characters
debuted so it also includes all the other
characters all the looks all the costumes
everything about the stories in the characters
that they created for those original stories.
So this would be that if the Steve Ditko estate
were successful and actually terminating marvel's
copyright ability to use the stuff from those
comics marvel and Sony would lose the ability
to use Peter Parker Spider-Man aunt May all
of his court characters in villains like the
sinister six villains Spider-Man's costume
in the same thing for the Stephen Strange
Doctor Strange character in other court characters
in villains and details from the doctor Strange
comics, so they would be able to use those
characters in the movies on the TV shows to
this isn't just a comic book thing.
So yes, it does sound like a big deal kind
of like they're basically shooting a giant
warning shot over marvel's bow this might
sound familiar marvel getting into big lawsuit
over Spider-Man because marvel and Sony got
into it over the film rights to the Spider-Man
character a couple years ago after Spider-Man
far from home came out it for a brief second
marvel did lose Spider-Man he was no longer
part of the MCU.
But that only lasted for a couple months at
best before marvel and Sony made nice they
worked out a new deal and now are getting
ready to watch Spider-Man and Doctor Strange
try their best to destroy reality during Spider-Man
no way home in December and make as many Spider-Man
puns as possible.
It is going to be some amazing Spider-Man
also no coincidence.
They also have a big doctor Strange movie
this coming right after that Doctor Strange
2 multiverse of madness how weird is it that
is a lawsuit over Spider-Man and Doctor Strange
before their giant to movies get ready to
happen the last Spider-Man movie far from
home made over $1 billion the box office and
even though the virus has affected movie earnings
in a big way this year there still a solid
chance the Spider-Man no way home will earn
close to $1 billion, especially of all the
rumors about Tobey Maguire in Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man cameo scenes are true if even a
fraction of those rumors wind up coming to pass
You can bet your ass is that everybody's gonna
want to go see that movie.
So with all this money flying around Spider-Man
and Doctor Strange the marvel movies, the
Disney plus series right now, being such big
business is no coincidence that Steve Ditko
heirs are trying to get into it with Marvel
over there big cash cow was really going on
here is the heirs are trying to get them some
of that sweet Spider-Man cheddar cheese and
Doctor Strange as part of the tuba Spider-Man
is probably the best example this their whole
argument is that because Steve did cocreated
the characters, his estate should hold the
copyrights them not marvel or Sony.
But even though I'm not a lawyer and most
of you probably aren't lawyers either their
pride couple of you that are watching this
video there is a lawyers or comic book creators
who are familiar with the situation this kind
of big lawsuit between OG comic book creators
and marvel sounds familiar.
Obviously, because is the exact same thing
that happened with Jack Kirby's estate a while ago
His estate also tried to sue Marvel and DC
comics separately with the exact same reason
for all the characters he created and he created
a ton of core Marvel characters.
But if you're asking what happened in that
Jack Kirby lawsuit obviously we saw all the
marvel movies, the past couple of years.
That means that they were unsuccessful kind
of yes Marvel and DC wound up settling with
the estate of Jack Kirby out-of-court because
when you as you talk about who owns the rights
these characters ultimately that were created
50,60, 70 even more years ago it gets a little complicated
So if you not familiar with how the rights
for all these huge comic book characters actually
work originally what happened when they were
all created back in the 1920s, 30s all the
way up to present day people like Stan Lee
Steve Ditko Jack Kirby the rest of the OG
creators were what you would all call work
for hire employees for Marvel and DC.
The big publishers back in the day, meaning
that their contracts of the time originally
said that they were supposed to create some
new comics new characters in those comics
in for that work they would get paid a fee
a salary in everything that they created was
going to be the property of Marvel and DC
that the time they were created.
Like back in the 1960s of her talking about
Spider-Man the amount of money that they were
paid to create those characters and write
these comics, which is the going rate for
typical publishers of that era.
Even if you adjust for inflation they were
paid a ton of money to Stanley and Steve to
co-wind of creating Spider-Man and Doctor
Strange in 1962 in 1963 respectively.
Everybody loves them, the comics cell super
well they going to have very successful careers
working at marvel making more comics crating
even more characters in for the most part
their contracts stay the same for that whole.
While they're creating all these giant comic
book characters.
They get paid their fees.
But at the time.
It just not a ton of money.
But here's the thing.
This is where all the lawsuits from Stan Lee
Steve Ditko Jack Kirby the other OG comic
book creators start the really big lawsuits
back in the day when they created those characters.
Originally they were only paid their fees
very small fees at that in their contracts
did not take into account any potential future
movies, TV shows, toys, or even video games
that Marvel would wind up making in the future.
Like we pay you $0.50 to create Spider-Man
and you create a Spider-Man we pay you $0.50
so the contract is been served.
We don't owe you any more money for Spider-Man.
So now in marvel started making a bunch of
extra money on the movies, the TV shows the
toys the videogames because none of the contracts
for these comic book creators explicitly said
that they were supposed to earn extra money
if the characters got used in different new
formats so Marvel for example never paid them
extra money.
So for example, even though the Tobey Maguire
Spider-Man movies back in the day earn billions
of dollars Steve Ditko didn't get an extra
penny from any of that it is just one example,
the videogames have earn billions and billions
of dollars he didn't get any extra money from
that stuff either you may remember a little
while ago infamously Stan Lee sued marvel
when the MCU got started because he was kind
of the face of the marvel brand in his original
contract didn't say that he was supposed to
earn extra money from movies or games.
For example, but because he was such a big
deal and such a big face for the brand he
was able to use his position to negotiate
a special new deal with Marvel that paid him.
I think was like a million or a couple million
dollars per year for the rest of his life
as a way for Marvel to say okay you even though
your original contract didn't say that you
were supposed to get extra money for all this
brand-new stuff you are so fundamental to
what Marvel became is a company in these billions
and billions of dollars in profits the burning
out the you deserve a very very small piece
of that.
And I think the idea was that the time is
that was also part of the idea of Stanley's
cameo scenes in all the marvel movies.
But Steve Ditko did not get a new deal like
that.
That was just Stan Lee that renegotiated that
special deal.
So that's kind of where were at with this
new lawsuit essentially it's the Steve Ditko
heirs trying to force a new negotiation with
Marvel for Spider-Man and Doctor Strange profits
because they kind of did the acyl thing of
not offering Steve Ditko any extra compensation
for being responsible for creating such a
huge cash cow for them.
Even the lawsuits all about Spider-Man and
Doctor Strange just talking about Spider-Man.
For example, he is one of the most profitable
most popular comic book characters in the
history of the world Spider-Man is a license
to print money for whoever owns him, so of
course Marvel is probably gonna renegotiate
a new deal with the Ditko estate give them
a little extra money and he's already credited
on all the Spider-Man movies, but they also
might make his on-screen credit a little more
prominent for future movies, so there's no
real threat of Marvel is Sony actually losing
the Spider-Man and Doctor Strange characters.
Technically the contracts are in favor of
Marvel having the copyrights not Steve Ditko estate
But as you can tell from all the bad press
that they were getting because the scarlet
Johansson black widow lawsuit Marvel does
not like long drawn out bad press like this
heading into a big movie premiere like Spider-Man
no way home do not be surprised if you hear
about this problem getting fixed before December
is not quite as big a deal as it sounds like
even though it is kind of a big deal and it's
no coincidence that the lawyers who are representing
the Steve Ditko estate are the same lawyers
who try to represent the Jack Kirby estate
when they tried to sue marvel for Jack Kirby
a long time ago.
They were unsuccessful, but they were able
to renegotiate a new deal for Jack Kirby out-of-court
so that's why state the same thing is probably
can happen for Steve Duco really the OG comic
book reader lawsuits are all about the original
publishing contracts they didn't have anything
to do with the movies.
Kevin Feige in the movie people actually really
do care about these original comic book creators
that's why Marvel is been changing a lot of
the way they do contracts with people in the
last couple of years.
Just to account for a lot of these issues
in this is unique to Marvel.
This also happens at DC comics all the time
to avert Warner Bros. and better news we will
be getting a new Spider-Man no way home trailer
in the next month or two.
Of course will do more videos about the movies
we get closer might venom let there be carnage
post credit scene video full Easter egg videos
and breakdowns videos will start posting later
next week after the movie comes out everywhere
in my full marvel what if episode eight video
will post next Wednesday.
So this a lot of really cool stuff coming
up make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss any those videos
everyone click here to learn what's going
on with the sinister six inside the Spider-Man
no way home trailer and click here for my
full marvel what if and credit scene video
for the infinity gauntlet Ultron.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!